[Musique]
là je pense qu'on vient de voir
une farine jeunes mâles
[Musique]
gaffe une colline et professeur de
littérature mais lorsqu'elle pénètre
dans ces bois foisonnant elle y trouve
une poésie qui s'exprime en chant et en
couleurs influencer ni l'expérience
d'émerveillement devant la nature
[Musique]
200 espèces d'oiseaux différentes lost
ici un paradis pour les ornithologues
amateurs déterminés à sauver ce fut gym
usités on dit souvent que le mont royal
est le poumon vert de montréal
ce paradis des ornithologues c'est cette
tache verte de la même superficie que le
parc de la montagne un deuxième poumon
vert potentiel quelques 210 hectares de
nature en pleine ville or l'endroit n'a
pas de nom ce n'est pas un parc c'est
quoi alors
au début des années 90 vers
saint-laurent rêve d'un parc industriel
à la fine pointe de la technologie pour
attirer des entreprises et créer des
emplois
on fonde le technoparc mais la sphère ne
connaît pas le succès escompté
si bien que pas mal de terrain de
secteurs demeurent en friche et regorge
de petits marais donc d'oiseaux si ce
que les gens appellent le secteur
municipal 60 hectares près de la moitié
des terrains appartiennent à la ville
tout à côté on trouve le secteur fédéral
avec 150 ha non fragmenté de nature tous
ces terres appartiennent au fédéral sous
la responsabilité quand même de adm donc
sous loué à adm les aéroports de
montréal qui qui gère en l'endroit kif
qui prennent d'édition et selon le plan
directeur da dmc terre sont disponibles
à des femmes développement c'est un
projet énorme d'ailleurs aéroports de
montréal envisage de permettre la
construction d'une nouvelle usine dans
un champ où viennent se reproduire les
papillons monarques
ce qui inquiète au plus haut point les
amants du parc sans nom david fleisher
de la coalition verte milite depuis des
années pour préserver le parc fantôme
si vous avez un mot pour décrire ce qui
va se passer ici c'est quoi oh mon dieu
ce criminel exactement ce criminel
aéroports de montréal nous a écrit que
ce projet n'était pas susceptible de
causer des effets environnementaux
négatifs importants dès 2012 montréal
qu'on soit le projet de joindre une
vaste portion des terres fédérales à
celle de la ville mais les négociations
longeur
mais jamais réussi il n'y a pas un autre
endroit où le gouvernement fédéral est
propriétaire de milieux naturels
la seul endroit cet essai alan desousa a
contacté son adversaire politique
mes alliés à la cause robert beaudry de
projet montréal et la ville a fait
adopter une résolution pour que ce
projet aboutisse il faut une stratégie
globale et l'on veut le travail avec le
fédéral
d'ailleurs en avril dernier adm a créé
un espace de protection 18 hectares sur
l'île 150 disponibles elle n'avait pas
le choix puisque une espèce en voie de
disparition le petit blond view nichée
autour de ce marais je parle que il faut
à ce moment-là avoir l'ambition de
réaliser vraiment une beau projet sinon
petit à petit cette terrain va être
développée par les villes par les
reports de montréal mais ultime à ma
demande est adressée au propriétaire du
terrain
ma demande est faite adressée à là
gouvernement fédéral mais à ottawa on
nous répond que ses adm qui décide
[Musique]
depuis des années catherine collins
arpente le parc son nom voit des routes
qui ne mènent nulle part se construire
des arbres abattus des marais asséchés
qu'est ce que ça va faire dans moby si
vous perdez cet endroit mais ça fait ça
sert le gosier quand même de se parler
la nature ça nous rend confort ça nous
donne de l'aide pour moi ça va être un
perte ça va être un deuil en fête est
aussi une perte énorme pour montréal
[Musique]